[Musique]
la colère de l'ouest canadien atteint
son paroxysme depuis l'élection fédérale
le mot-clic que what is it qui fait
référence bien sûr au président du
royaume uni a fait son apparition sur
les réseaux sociaux certains signes d'un
regain d'un mouvement indépendantiste
lab a d'ailleurs il ya des
rassemblements qui sont prévues
aujourd'hui en alberta d'où vient au
juste ce mouvement on en parle tout de
suite avec frédéric boily il est
politologue et professeur agrégé au
campus saint-jean de l'université de
l'alberta
bonjour monsieur boyer bonjour alors sur
quoi s'appuie ce mouvement
indépendantiste albertain 12 dimensions
la première dimension et économique il
faut pourvoir de cette idée séparatistes
ou indépendantistes 1 voir le moteur
économique albertain commencé à
fonctionner à bas régime et même à très
bas régime et c'est ce qui est arrivé
finalement depuis 2014-2015 et ça s'est
accentué par la suite en 2016 et 2010 à
savoir une économie albertaine avec des
prix de l'énergie qui était plus bas
moins de rentrées fiscales des taux
d'emploi lubbock ailleurs au pays
l'économie va pas très bien
contrairement au regard des tableaux sur
le taux de chômage
donc ça va pas bien - le taux de chômage
qui a littéralement explosé notamment du
côté de calgary qui se faisait une
fierté d'être une force de capital
économique évidemment pour l'alberta
mais même pour l'ouest en général et qui
voyait les taux de chômage atteint le
même jusqu à vide pour cent certain
moment donc il ya une base économique
qui est nommé aussi la dimension
politique qui est particulièrement
important parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une conjugaison des deux ce que je veux
dire par une dimension politique
c'est le fait que i dont les avoirs le
développement de la perception que le
gouvernement fédéral et tout
particulièrement un gouvernement qui est
libéral est indifférent à ces problèmes
économiques étaient indifférents à
essayer de faire en sorte que le pétrole
us est exporté à l'extérieur via des
pipelines et même plus et du côté je
voudrais des mouvements indépendantistes
c'est dire que non seulement
gouvernement libéral le gouvernement
fédéral ait une différence c'est qu'eux
ils essaient de mettre des bâtons dans
les roues de l'industrie pétrolière et
donc c'est lorsqu'on est à cette
conjugaison de ces deux dimensions qu'on
voit ce regain d'intérêt pour
l'indépendantisme et lucky particulier
en argent depuis cette frustration c'est
toujours cette frustration là entre
l'est et l'ouest d'ailleurs une
caricature la qui a été publiée dans le
monde
la voir à l'écran ça démontre assez bien
la frustration des albertains on voit
justin trudeau la queue devant des
enfants pour qu'ils présentent enfin les
prairies de tout donner au québec c'est
vraiment ce sentiment là qui est vécu
par les albertains et qui nourrit cette
frustration politique c'est ce sentiment
qui le nourrit c'est un sentiment humain
qui postent l'élection
général il ya aussi des critiques qui se
font également contre la colombie
britannique
donc ça aussi des fois un peu comme un
métronome vers le québec vers la
colombie britannique
ou alors directement vers ottawa et ça
conduit à cette espèce de grands
tableaux comme coin lamberto est en
quelque sorte assiégé par des forces
extérieures et qu' on est un dû coûter
albertain incapable de faire avancer
quelques projets que ce soit de
construction pipeline neutre en ce
montant même s'il a été acheté par le
gouvernement ferrals certains pensent
encore que c'est un projet qui ne se
réalisera revanche les questions de
réalisme c'est le dernier point final et
on n'en a pas ou plus jamais donc ça
fait en sorte que les efforts qui sont
faits par le gouvernement albertain
mêmes souvenirs aux démocrates pour
faire avancer des projets de
construction n'aboutisse police et
beaucoup on se retrouve dans cette danse
moment ils ont séparatistes ou
indépendante c'est ce qui tendrait de se
transformer en mouvement
et lorsqu'on se pose c'est est-ce que ça
va se transformer véritablement un
mouvement véritablement mérité ou un
parti politique parce qu'on part cette
frustration là mais ce qu'annie s'est
fait élire un peu un sur cette
frustration mais il ya qualifié quand
même dit rationnels l'idée de
l'indépendance est là parce que c'est
possible probable qu'ils aient eu
qu'on ait vers l'indépendance de
l'alberta moi je pense que c'est très
peu probable parce que c'est réussi à
concrétiser ou à mettre un projet qui
serait sur la table et qui serait
concret et c'est pourquoi comme l'avait
mentionné jason kenney a mentionné que
roger était rationnel et en même temps
on ne peut pas l'écarter on ne peut pas
écarter évidemment tout ce sentiment de
frustration parce que ce soit 2
tentation de dire non plus que ce n'est
pas concret puisque c'est difficile de
réaliser parce qu'on est plus dans les
mêmes conditions que dans les années 80
où les années 90 des jeux les bandes
autochtones disent que si jamais il y
avait quelques projets politiques que ce
souhait qu'elles devraient avoir voix au
chapitre et une aux dimensions aussi qui
est différente par rapport à ce qui se
passait auparavant c'est le fait aussi
que maintenant vous avez les médias
sociaux et médias sociaux peuvent
amplifier jusqu'à un certain point
tout ce mouvement et en même temps ça ça
le rend un peu plus difficile à
maîtriser mais le côté concret parce que
vous avez vous avoir les médias sociaux
une fois pas l'indépendance via les
médias sociaux il faut nécessairement un
véhicule politique avec un projet est
sûr pour le moment c'est ce qu'on ne
voit pas encore à l'horizon des médias
sociaux
le mot qui circule de plus en plus on
verra ce que sarko méfait alors
brièvement en trois secondes là il ya
une bonne différence donc entre le
mouvement indépendantiste alberta et
celui du québec
les boss du mouvement nationaliste
indépendantiste au québec se dit base
culture et l'identité de préservation
des identités culturelles alors qu'ici
c'est là en fait c'est la très belle
préservation de l'identité économique
d'ailleurs quand on veut solistes on
voit c'est de la liberté économique de
l'alberta qui est défendue et par la
chute d'autres valable mais c'est la
question d'économie qui est prédominant
on se reconnaît plus de côtés de
l'alberta quand on se compare avec le
sud qu'avec l'est du pays
merci beaucoup monsieur bonnet on va
bien sûr suivre la situation en alberta
merci de nous avoir éclairé un peu
l'action ces quarts à des rassemblements
aujourd'hui on va suivre ça merci
beaucoup bonne journée à vous suivre une
journée